especially with bringing RD Laing on
board for the 8 months he was with me
it's very difficult to get into any kind
of commentary on society with hearty
lank sitting there how it was odd it was
great I mean you know the the preface
everyone gives his [ __ ] love Artie
he's hilariously funny so quick and and
just a goofy knock around regular guy
but the demons man
the demons it was it was kind of rough
to deal with like I said I'm a relaxed
guy if I already didn't show up one day
I do the show myself didn't he do the
show with Opie for a while no he was a
guest on Opie show and and I guess Opie
approached him to be a co-host or
something he said no oh but yeah I was
never part of the show I thought he was
gonna be part of the show yeah there was
kind of a rumor going around for a while
so when he came on I was like it's not
gonna kill me if he doesn't show up you
know for a day every so often because
I'll just do the show myself but it
turned out to be a little more than that
and there was some days that were really
good in other days where it was a little
frayed around the edges and you know
redundant he's got a different kind of
demons
yeah like Beelzebub he's got like the
main demon he really does man and it's
so [ __ ] sad to say because I mean
there's no question about the talent
there he's he's hilarious and a great
guy great guy you always hear that ya
always hear that yeah
I remember when we hired him it was I
was at the Comedy Cellar and Dave Attell
came he goes so you're working with
already like yeah goes well welcome to
the wonderful world of the 3 a.m. phone
calls and not being able to find and
like oh [ __ ] what did we get ourselves
into and and that's kind of what we got
ourselves into but again I mean I had a
great time his he's one of the funniest
[ __ ] especially on a mic like
that the the who would think that when
Jackie Martling left the Stern Show
they'd be able to replace him with
somebody that was just funny as [ __ ] and
and have legendary shows with with Artie
on
and you know he he definitely earned a
place in in broadcast history but we
just you know after eight months it got
a little too crazy too unpredictable and
he needs some predictability what was
what was bad about it well it was the
the attendance issue was a little odd
like a principal yeah yeah the
attendance he wasn't he was tardy and
and there were some days he was [ __ ]
just most days he was awesome but there
were some days where you know the heads
down it was kind of kind of a little
iffy and you know regardless I know he
knows that too I mean he's he's he lives
in that body so you know he knows it so
it was a little odd and then we picked
up Dave Landau who's a young comic out
of Detroit he filled in a couple of
times when we had him as a guest on the
show and then he filled in a couple of
times during Artie's few sabbaticals
that he was away for a week or so and me
and Dave just hit it off he's got a
great sense of humor he's a little
twisted he's got a great backstory
the guy was just a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
for a lot his stories about like drunk
driving he crashed every car he had he
was arrested 15 times before he was 18
like just a disaster and you look at him
now he's got a great wife a beautiful
kid he's working comic and he's awesome
he did he knows how to co-host my show
he gets it he we don't step on each
other he he knows exactly what to throw
in and when so really happy with with
Dave Landau he's great only did one show
with him the last time I was in town
yeah he's great yeah he's a good guy
dude yes smart and really decent like
it's so weird to see people that you
didn't know when they were such fuck-ups
and [ __ ] up cuz like you know you
almost want to go alright come on we'll
just drink one night I want to see what
a disaster you are you know